hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar irrigation
essentials basics biology and best
practices
i am matthew jay grassi i'm the new
editor of greenhouse management magazine
so glad you could take the time and join
us today for this presentation
in this webinar we will be having a
conversation with shay
donald a field technician for the
professional technical services
horticulture department as well as his
teammate
marisol camacho irrigation layout and
design
engineer both of whom are with the
hawthorne gardening company
just we're going to learn a little bit
more today about mastering proper
irrigation in greenhouse facilities
before we do get started i have a few
housekeeping notes to go over
number one this webinar is being
recorded and it will be available in a
few days
on our website secondly we will have a q
a period we will have time for your
questions at the end of this webinar so
please submit all of your questions at
any time during the presentation
by using the q a function that's at the
bottom of the window there
in your zoom task bar one more
quick housekeeping note the views
expressed during this webinar are those
of the speaker
our speakers and not necessarily of
greenhouse management magazine or
gie media this webinar does not
constitute
an endorsement of the vendor or
speaker's views
products services or advice
now i am pleased to introduce today's
speakers
shay donald and marisol camacho first
about shea
shea is a field technician for the
professional technical services
horticulture department at hawthorne
gardening company
shea has a background in greenhorse
horticulture technology
he manages the design and construction
of vegetable production facilities
across across british columbia
and he's joining us today from vancouver
marisol has been with hgc for about
six months and previously had a year of
experience in kitchen ventilation
she graduated from oregon state
university cascades with a degree in
energy
systems engineering which is the
multi-disciplinary
degree it combines uh aspects of
mechanical
electrical and industrial engineering
courses
and then with a focus on energy and
developing a systems approach to solving
problems
role in background has allowed marisol
to sharpen this holistic mindset
because while her focus is primarily on
irrigation
she also does benching and lighting
design for greenhouse facilities
and really all indoor ag facilities as
well
marisol recognizes the importance of
understanding the impacts that changes
no matter how big or small in your
growing environment
can have on your irrigation system and
more importantly
on your plants so that's just a little
bit
about our two panelists today that
you'll be hearing from
now we're going to get into the meat and
potatoes of the presentation
so i throw it over to shea and we'll get
started
okay so question number one
what is drought stress and how does it
affect
crop development awesome thanks matthew
thanks for the
introduction so i guess starting out
um yeah we want to talk about drought
stress
and what that means to growers big and
small
so it drought stress is a general term
that can mean quite a few things but
overall it's just when
a plant doesn't have enough water to
maintain its physiological processes
and so it might start shutting things
down in order to prevent
an excess loss of moisture
so kind of the symptoms that you might
see
in a plant or in a crop are fairly
familiar to
even non-growers because as a plant
has water loss that's excessive
as that's occurring it's losing water in
its vacuoles
when it within its cells and
that starts to drop what's called the
turgor pressure
that keeps plants upright so it's a
fairly familiar
thing to see is a plant that's drooping
its leaves are facing downwards as it
loses that
force that's keeping the leaves upright
so there's a number of things that are
happening on
the cell level as this is going on
on plants leaves they have stomatal
openings
that open and close to allow
water vapor to escape as well as oxygen
but it also brings carbon dioxide into
the leaf
which is essential for photosynthesis so
as the plant realizes oh i don't have
enough water to
keep things going i have it shuts down
those stomatal openings
shuts them to try and prevent that water
loss it can't completely prevent it
but it will slow it down which also puts
a stop
on photosynthesis so bringing this back
around to
growers we obviously want to
keep the plants photosynthesizing as
much as possible
so for growers professional and amateur
alike
you don't want your plant to experience
this drought stress
because that's going to reduce the
photosynthesis which is going to reduce
your yield potential
and for greenhouse growers that means
lost dollars
you don't want to be keeping your lights
and fans and everything running
while your plants are just sitting there
trying desperately not to
lose water so that's kind of an acute
drought stress
situation that's where the plant hasn't
adapted
to what's going on in the root zone it's
just been exposed to extremely dry
conditions
and it's trying really hard not to to
die basically
but over time because plants
are are smart uh you know they
they are able to adapt to their
conditions because they don't have the
luxury of
picking up their roots and moving 20
feet closer to a stream
so in a natural environment they have to
change the way that they use water in
order to
adapt to those drier conditions and so
this is something that is a bit more
nefarious
and something that we really want to
push and and talk about today
is um just because your crop
looks okay and it looks like
everything's growing well
that your plants could still be
experiencing drought stress
it's just that they have adapted to it
now and they do things like
they reduce the number of stomatal
openings on their leaves
they produce smaller leaves and
ultimately
it again reduces your yield potential
and it reduces the amount of
photosynthesis that's going on day to
day
so if you have a crop that is
consistently exposed to just
minor drought stress conditions you end
up with a crop that might
look subjectively fine
but it's actually growing smaller and
producing less yield overall and that's
that's kind of what we're all about and
what we're all about
preventing is we want our plants just
drinking like crazy and therefore
growing like crazy
that's ideal
interesting shy as you noted we want to
avoid this
end of end of the year yield hit so yeah
limiting drought stress
is super important um so so guys what
factors into irrigation system planning
i i feel like this question will be a
perfect fit for marisol
in her uh systems approach and kind of
having an all-encompassing
approach to to a project
yeah so this question really it touches
on a lot of different things so really
you know whether you're greenhouse or
you're you know completely indoors
hydroponics hydroponic growing really
does require a holistic approach
um so the various inputs in the growing
environment will have an impact on the
irrigation system and its needs
but ultimately you know everything is
intertwined so they're all going to
affect
each other in different ways so one of
the biggest things
is going to be lights in the your
growing environment
switching the type of light or switching
the type of photo period of light
or the length of photo period of light
in a greenhouse or indoor facility will
ultimately impact the environment for
example
a big thing is switching from high
pressure sodium lights
uh to leds so switching to led lights
actually reduces the
amount of radiant heat available to the
plant and it will ultimately infect
evap evapotranspiration rates another
thing that can affect
your plant is the amount of plant
biomass or the pruning techniques used
across different high value crops
vegetables hemp etc
this decreases the thermal mass that's
ultimately available
and will impact the airflow that's
moving through both the beneath the
canonical
and above it's also decreasing the
surface area available for transpiration
as i mentioned up before
and also different types of plants are
all going to have different
ideal irrigation parameters so you're
going to need to adjust depending on the
type of crop that you're growing but
ultimately the type of species you are
as well and you know this is a big part
of i think hydroponic growing is that we
don't know everything about different
types of plants and how they truly
behave
and what are the different buttons that
can kind of push them into the next
stage of growth
and then another big thing is going to
be the impact on your heating and
cooling
so when you are irrigating and you are
doing
small and frequent irrigation events
you're going to put a lot less stress on
your hvac equipment versus if you're
doing
very infrequent larger volume irrigation
events so instead of putting a bunch of
water into the room
at one time you're putting a little bit
incrementally over time
and putting less stress on your system
and then another huge part as we can all
imagine is what's going on at the plant
there is the media type that you decide
to pick and then also the pot size
um as we have seen in hydroponic growing
three of the most popular growing medias
are going to be coco choir
rock wool and peat and so these all have
different benefits
but they also all require different
irrigation strategies and that's
important to consider
you shouldn't be watering six-inch
rockwell cubes the same as like
five gallons of coco coir so a really
important part of it
and i'm gonna hit a little bit on kind
of the
the benefits of each of these um growing
medias and then
also this irrigation strategies you
could use so first we have coco coir
as many people know it holds moisture
really well it allow
it allows for a lot of oxygenation and
it's really easy to use it's very user
friendly
and if it's properly treated prior to
use within the manufacturing
process it's going to be great for your
plants
it retains water for a long period of
time and can handle fewer
fewer irrigation events and it can
handle you know potentially mission
an irrigation event or any mistakes that
a new grower may make um and this also
has um the second most aeration
available to the plant
next to rockwool so going into rockwool
as mentioned it has the most aeration
available um
it also it does require a high level of
skill to efficiently irrigate
um and that's where people can kind of
get messed up using rockwool especially
if they're new to growing on a larger
scale
and lastly it's also not the most
sustainable growing media so that's a
kind of potential downside of choosing
rockwell
and then we have we have pete last pete
is very very easy to use as we've seen
it's available in a lot of consumer
grade soils that are out there
however with all the positives it does
have
it is a little bit more application
specific it cannot be
as well suited for higher intensity
crops
because of the potential for um over
saturation of water
and then lastly we have pot size bigger
pots are going to require less frequent
irrigation events
and but it is going to be harder to
control the moisture content available
and also
there's the potential for there is
potential for a greater margin of error
in terms of
if you water a little bit too much it's
probably going to be okay
versus if you have a smaller pot over
watering can have a much more severe
impact on
plant health throughout the growth cycle
and then small pots obviously yield
themselves really well to the strategy
of pulse irrigation
and it's really good it's really easy to
maintain moisture and aeration in the
root zone when you're putting in a lot
of smaller
irrigation events as a team at hawthorne
we always strive to design our systems
with consideration to all these factors
and to allow for flexibility within your
system
we want to make sure that you know if
you decide to expand
by you know adding a couple more plants
to each of your rooms
we're going to be able to handle that
and that's a really important part of
planning
your irrigation system and we'll get a
little bit more into this as we
get further into the webinar great stuff
there marisol
um you kind of touched on it a little
bit there at the end
but are there some preventative measures
that that
growers and their teams should be
keeping in mind during the design
process when they're designing the
irrigation system that they want to use
in the greenhouse to account for
potential changes down the road
such as maybe going from hps to led
or maybe adding some additional acreage
that you hadn't planned on originally
but you want to scale up and expand any
any high level thoughts there that you
guys can share with us
i guess real there's a wealth of
problems unfortunately that you could
have in a
in a growing facility so i mean i'll
just touch on some of the you know
i guess the most common ones we see one
of the first things is the
improperly sized equipment or placed
equipment
um and within that also designing for
redundancy
if you have a pump for each different
room per say
in some indoor facility uh you'll be
able to accommodate any potential
addition of more plants versus if you
have you know only two pumps handling
like six rooms
there are as many pumps or as many
pieces of equipment
here i'm actually going to pause there
sorry that didn't flow out very well
another potential issue of poorly
designed irrigation systems is going to
be improperly sized or placed equipment
whether that be pumps pipes filters or
valves
and it's also going to be designing for
redundancy it's really important to
account for oh my gosh
sorry i have to start over that just not
flowing out very well
okay there are a lot of common issues
that can potentially show up
in a drip irrigation system one of them
many of them can be due to
improperly sized or placed equipment
such as pumps pipes filters and valves
we could also see signs in terms of
fungus gnats or different types of pests
that are
present because of an excess amount of
water and then we could also see
unwanted
plant stress and stress plants are more
susceptible to pests and they're more
susceptible
to just all the environmental factors as
they become more stressed out
specifically some of the things that we
definitely do as designers is we
always aim to design redundant systems
we want to make sure that we have enough
pumps to cover any potential expansion
we have large enough pumps that can
cover any potential addition of plants
and any increases in flow rates it's
also important to introduce
automation and monitoring into your
system this can help you keep track
and have real-time data showing that you
are delivering the proper amount of
water and types of nutrients to your
plants
and i can i'm going to leave this open
for shay to answer some
add some quick tidbits too
um yeah so some preventative items that
madisol touched on
we tend to want to allow growers the
flexibility to
you know if they want to change their
planting density down the road
or modify their irrigation scheduling or
strategies that they have the
the control aspect and and the ability
to do so
um and so like madison mentioned um
we would try and include some kind of
baked in
um wiggle room so to speak in
in the design uh whether it's slightly
over-sizing pipes i think is fairly
common so that it can handle a higher
flow rate down the road
or having a larger pump or something
that has
a variable frequency drive that allows
it to maintain the pressure that's
needed because
one of the biggest issues that we see
are commonly improperly sized
items like that and what happens is
it might work today but as soon as you
change a factor or
change something in your growing style
down the road
then you're going to have problems so
just trying to account for that on the
front end and also understand that
growers do like to change these things
and and kind of play around with stuff
is is what we try to incorporate into
any of our recommendations or any of our
work
i would say also another big thing too
is
getting a grasp of the facility as well
understanding where the water is
actually coming into your building and
making sure that when you're sizing
those pumps that you're accounting for
any potential pressure loss over those
lengths
and there's a lot of different things
absolutely yes
oh and just adding to that too just how
much water do they have access to
you know we've had situations where
people have to drill
extra wells for example or go to the
city and get a
increase which is probably fairly common
among
some of the viewers today so and water
quality as well
that's another part as well and
especially as
people are growing in different parts of
the country it's important to understand
what types of minerals and things are in
your water so that you can properly
clean it before it goes to your plants
so guys it sounds like there's there's a
lot of variables there a lot of moving
parts where
it it behooves you as a grower to have
some a team of experts kind of on your
side helping you through this process
and making sure you're planning for what
you need down the road
um you know we we've touched on a few
different production systems a few
different growing styles
for greenhouse growing specifically
how is irrigation different when you're
when you're deploying it within a
greenhouse versus
another type of indoor facility and what
are some of the common issues or
problems that you
see typically in a greenhouse operation
that's adding irrigation yeah so
greenhouse is
pretty interesting because um you know i
had someone
tell me that you know greenhouse growing
is kind of like
regular agriculture but for control
freaks and
i think that's that's kind of true
because you you take all these things
that
in an agricultural setting you have no
control over
um you know your soil type to some
degree
the temperature the humidity the wind
those are all things you have to contend
with
um whereas in a greenhouse or an indoor
setting
which takes it kind of to the next
extreme um you get to control all those
items
you know to some degree so when you have
to
deal with irrigation in a greenhouse
setting
it's going to be different than in a
field as well as indoor
and compared to in a field you know
your crops have essentially an unlimited
amount of room for their roots to grow
into
and so you can get away with not
irrigating for
sometimes multiple days and the crops
are going to do just fine
and in fact a lot of what irrigation
management is in
a field versus in a greenhouse or indoor
is just accounting for you know what you
get from the rain
your soil type the environmental
conditions
and things like that and there's there's
a lot more buffer there and a lot more
room for you to take time and make those
decisions
uh in a greenhouse setting when you're
growing in soilless media especially
um now you don't have the luxury of that
time
and what you need to do with this
reduced
root ball without with this lower amount
of volume for the roots to grow into
you need to increase the frequency of
your irrigations significantly
now in a greenhouse compared to an
indoor setting indoor setting it's kind
of
you know you have great big hvac systems
and and the goal is
to keep your environment bang on
exactly the same throughout the entire
day
that kind of makes things a bit easier
because now you just
you can say i want to irrigate every 30
minutes
and give it 200 mils and just do that
all day
starting two hours after your lights
turn on for example
in a greenhouse there's going to be some
compounding factors such as
you know light levels
and the humidity and temperature which
you have some control over but it's not
going to be that perfect perfect control
that you see in an idealized indoor
setting so what a lot of modern
controllers do environmental controllers
for greenhouses
they kind of factor a lot of those
things in automatically
obviously the grower still has to make a
lot of decisions
on the front end about what those
parameters are going to be
but a lot of it is just through these
very complex
systems that exist that assist growers
with
making those decisions and and i think
one of the most
um recent additions to this
is kind of the uh there's been a lot of
sensing soil moisture sensing technology
that's kind of taking off
in stairless media these days which is
very exciting because now
you know that's the most direct way to
tell how much water is my plant getting
is
well how much water is there you can
indirectly monitor it by looking at
things like
like i was saying light humidity etc
but this allows you to really get the
plant eye view so to speak
and just just to add to that really
quickly
doing your irrigation scheduling using
sensors the sensor-based setpoint
irrigation really has the potential to
reduce your water volume significantly
in your operation
and despite also the low cost of water
there are a lot of potential economic
benefits that may result
from this in terms of reduced labor
fertilizer requirements and then disease
control
interesting guys it sounds like uh using
some of these advanced high-tech ec
and soil mon soil moisture sensors
are is something more advanced
greenhouse growers are
are doing today um are there any other
advanced irrigation techniques that
you're seeing
from a lot of greenhouse operations that
are working well yeah absolutely so it's
it's very interesting because i think a
lot of
the studies going on nowadays it's it's
really you want to be able to give your
crop
the least amount of water possible while
still maintaining that yield
that's that's desired because
sustainability
is going to be the number one issue you
know moving forward for a lot of folks
and i think water use is going to be
front of mind for
for that as well um
and so you know actually utilizing
drought stress itself
is something that is also already being
done
in a lot of vegetable crops for example
crop steering if anyone
is familiar with like tomato cucumber
pepper production that's sort of
growing you're you've got an
indeterminate plant that wants to both
be producing vegetative leaves as well
as productive
generative fruits and so
how growers kind of tell the plant
hey you should be producing more leaves
or more
fruits uh one of the one of the largest
tools or most immediate tools that
growers have in their belt
is uh through irrigation scheduling
and so this is called crop steering i'm
not sure if i mentioned it before
but um and what you can do is
essentially
by delaying your irrigation a little bit
in the morning adjusting a few key
environmental factors
you can sort of signal the plant that
it might be receiving less water moving
forward and so it kind of activates some
of those
processes we were talking about earlier
but without really reducing
the photosynthesis photosynthetic
ability of the plant that's the ideal
so by kind of running things drier so to
speak
you signaled the plant to produce more
fruit whereas if you have
more of a well-saturated consistently
moist
media then the plant kind of thinks hey
i can relax a bit
and start producing more leaves so
that's one of the key tools but
but there are i think going to be many
more moving forward and this application
i believe will extend to other crops
there are a lot of
studies that have been done on crops
that produce
essential oils and especially terpene
type
volatile chemicals that
humans might find desirable because we
can extract that and it smells nice
and you know there's a lot of crops out
there even medicinal ones that
that that is beneficial and there have
been studies that show
that if you kind of drought stress the
plants towards the end of their
production cycle
that they might produce more of these
chemicals sometimes they can be
protective chemicals and a lot of the
reason that they're
even being produced might not entirely
be known yet
but again i think that focusing on
irrigation
as a tool is um extremely exciting it's
something i'm
quite passionate about
excellent marisol anything to add to
that or anything you wanted to say there
well all great points that shea brought
up and um
also as a somebody with background in
energy and sustainability
i really look forward to seeing the
different advances and research that
will continue going into
understanding how irrigation can really
affect plant physiology
and plant outputs
excellent guys we're coming up to the
end of this presentation this is i feel
like this has been a great use of
everyone's time
talking about something that maybe not
as much
emphasis is put on as light selection or
genetic selection or some of these
things growers are very focused on when
they're planting a crop
but just as important obviously putting
a bow on this whole presentation
how can you any how can you avoid
drought stress
in the greenhouse yeah so avoiding
drought stress in the greenhouse
it starts from the pre-planning right it
starts from when you're
getting ready to construct your building
and what you have to do at that point
is you got to choose the right partners
um because
uh you want someone that's not only
going to understand
irrigation and drought stress but you
want
a partner who can kind of give you the
whole holistic picture
connect the dots connect things to your
growing media your growing style your
crop et cetera et cetera et cetera
and ideally someone who is going to be
there when
they hand you the keys um and this is
you know selfishly the plug for
hawthorne because
that's exactly what we do um we have a
team
that myself and matthew solar a part of
that's made up of
horticulturists mechanical engineers
lighting and electrical engineers as
well as design
and technical support that really
brings all those dots together whether
it's a greenhouse
indoor outdoor application
we're here to assist growers
to get the maximum yield and
the best possible crop that they can
really well sums it up shay and i just
like to add to that
is that you know throughout the whole
design process and project process we're
here
um before and we're here after and even
if we don't have a solution
for everything we're here to make sure
that it will integrate with anything
else that you choose
and that everything will work in unison
okay that does it for the presentation
uh
segment of our of our talk here now
we're going to open it up to audience
question and answer
so if you had any questions for shea or
marisol
that you wanted to get an answer for
today go ahead and type those into the q
and a
button at the bottom of your zoom window
there
and hit submit and we will start
answering some questions